eigentlich muss das schwarze das zombie
dingen sein doch noch einmal lukas kurz
du kannst du auch spielen mal sowas von
kindlich nur einmal hat man sowas wollen
billig lässt sich schmecken
die suche ist doch immer so riechen doch
gar nicht richtig dreckig gewesen aber
noch einmal noch hier ja jetzt richtig
gut aus das für witzig wie das bei und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja hat ich hoffe natürlich geht es
gut
ja ich weiß nicht wann dieses video
online kommt ich glaube gar nicht mal
heute also wir drehen das heute am
freitag in letzter zeit kam jetzt leider
nicht so regelmäßig videos das hat dann
einen bestimmten grund ich habe meinen
rucksack mit all meinen wert samen
kalorien sonstiges hier gern noch mal
ein flugverbot sagt wenn ihr denn
irgendwo in köln schreibt mir sehr gerne
bitte wirklich nur dann wenn es wirklich
ernst gemeint ist macht mich irgendwie
spaß dauert so waren wirklich sehr viele
sachen drin und wir fangen heute an oder
wir machen weiter vielleicht mal so mit
einem video das freue mich selbst war
letztens kam nämlich ein neuer park von
neue food trends aus dem letzten monat
und da habe ich immer die seite von new
germany zur hilfe genommen
und ja das gesehen also die betreiberin
der seite sie ist selber stewardess hat
mir ein paar videos zukommen lassen ich
zeig euch mal ganz kurz damit überhaupt
besteht gegen bis zu verdecken dass ich
neulich immer 1000 follower bekommen
haben ist das war da los aber ich
gedacht wissen wie eine verlor in
geschrieben hat haye der alex auf folgt
der alten alex w
ein glück wenn ich danke dir und als
großes dankeschön dafür bekommst du von
mir ein überraschungspaket aus amerika
mit lauter leckereien
ja du siehst ja das war in amerika
unterwegs und hat dort für mich ein
gekauft und mir ganz viele sachen wohl
zu kommen das und ich habe gedacht das
ist eigentlich ein video wert oder
ich bin mal gespannt was auf mich
zukommt das ding ist nämlich wir ziehen
das jetzt vor wir mit habe ich hab ja
ich hoffe da sind jetzt nicht nur
süßigkeiten drin
falls doch ist auch egal aber das hier
ist das paket was
von ihr bekommen habe ich weiß da steht
jetzt dhl drauf sie hat die ganzen
sachen mitgenommen hat deutschland von
hamburg aus hierhin geschickt weil sie
glaube ich in hamburg wohnt weil sonst
wer wird das ewig dauern dass das
ankommt
und ja ich bin mal gespannt das aber gar
keine flagge drauf da machen wir noch
ins amt heraus
juni kann man hier mit karte sogar
ziemlich professionell was man wie man
sagen hallo alex mit diesem
überraschungspaket schicke ich dir die
brand neuesten produkte aus den usa ich
bin gespannt ob du einen kittel drop
erwischt der nacht fährt rotteten zombie
schmeckt hh der geschmack der brandneuen
orio newtv indischen könnt ihr das
nochmal lesen
du kannst dir absoluten sich lesen ja
das ist auch schwierig ist halt meine
schriften und der geschmack der
brandneue thorium jüdischen ich hab sie
auf und werde sie probieren und viel
spaß wünsche ich dir beim vernaschen und
noch einmal vielen dank
ja sehr gerne was soll ich auch wieder
einzelne hier ist echt ne menge kohle
raus einzelnen rausholen ich weiß jetzt
den vogelfang markt dass man hier mit
anfangen hast du schon mal gesehen
mit sneakers allmend weiter
den anfang schon ganz gut wahrscheinlich
dass jetzt wieder ein absolutes
süßigkeiten kaufen da bin ich jetzt
schon gespannt was heißt alm und ein
muster wenn die swiss stärker in die
kommentare
alle allem wasser ist offen darunter
stammend schauen wir dass wir vielleicht
mal google heißt mandl butter schmeckt
auf jeden fall meist nur extrem süß muss
man sagen
warte mal was haben wir denn jetzt hier
noch tun ich bin mal gespannt weil ich
packe ja auch oftmals halt diese
boxen aus von dieser firma fun asche die
welt vielleicht schicken die mir ja auch
noch eine zu aus amerika mal gucken ob
der andere sachen drin sind oder
ähnliche hier so als nächstes haben wir
im moment pumpkin pie möchte das noch
bis jetzt oder wie kürbiskuchen fiskus
kommt kein fall kann das gemeinte
luftkrieg den kunden pakete halloween
ach ja stimmt ja auch gesagt das ist ein
paket in halloween paket sagen wir mal
so ich packs von bisschen er aus die
riechen gar nicht nach schokolade oder
so wie suche ich so auch ein mann liegt
noch gar nicht richtig nach
möglichkeiten der gründe warum ist man
aber eigentlich gut weiße schokolade das
und voll geil ich möchte aber nach
winter heute heftig auf diese farben
kann an dynamik
soll ich dann nicht die sich ja auch
machen direkt noch die andere hier haben
wir erst einmal vorlesen was darauf
steht kuckucks dunkle schokolade mir was
du kennst ja diese christi oder ach das
ist so cornflakes mäßig war gut probleme
aber die schmecken wie diese normalen
küste von hermann genauso wie können die
auf derzeit aber sind top 3 3 also vater
ist die hier nicht gibt kann man ja
schon so sagen jetzt haben wir danach
ein paar mehr in sachen drin
ich bin mal gespannt geht ziemlich in
deutschland kann man hier skittles die
gibt es garantiert nicht in deutschland
nicht in deutschland zählt nichts gibt
es sonne richten
aber woran liegt es denn dass das jedes
unternehmen oder so große wut marken
sagt jetzt mal halt von land zu land
unterschiedliche produkte machen
vielleicht geschmack und in sohland ist
der geschmack halt unterschiedlichen
manches verkauft ja aber was ich jetzt
in amerika gut verkauft sollte sich doch
auch hier gut verkaufen aber naja egal
obwohl seine drin
ich hatte irgendwann im letzten video
genau das war dieses food trends aus dem
letzten monat
sie ist hier kann man hier so neue
skittles skills smoothies sind aber
eigentlich schon mal ganz lecker aus
dadurch noch so eine skittles sorte drin
die wahren ultra gut die hatten so
leicht ein joghurt beigeschmack baut sie
sind diese songs kittel geil ich habe
wassermelonen achter können
da kann es vom geschmack war sein wir
gucken was hast du zusammen bist du
hattest unified messaging black cherry
louis gamen blackberry bluetrack berry
und rotten zombie also ich weiß nicht ob
ich gerade war ich probiere mal noch ein
paar also kannst du immer zombie haben
unsere schmeckt halt scheiße was
schmeckt denn das zombie es kein zombie
bei eigentlich muss das schwarze das
zombie dingen sein einmal lukas kruse
kommt so auch spielt man sowas vollen
kindlich nur einmal nennt man so etwas
wohl und wittlich lass dir schmecken
schmeckt jetzt gar nicht so schlimm aber
schmeckt so kannst du diese sachen mit
kosten so was also ist ja interessant
das ist dass das hier nicht gibt
deswegen ich hoffe für euch ist das auch
interessant vor allem für die edelfans
eine sache habe ich hier noch die ich
sehr interessant findet müsste wie oreo
was ist was verbirgt sich dahinter denn
also sind dann verschiedene geschmäcker
hinter oder gäste flavour ach so müsste
wie flatscreen aber ich weiß das ist
übelst man muss den geschmack erwarten
dann kann man beim gewinnspiel mitmachen
und kann 50.000 euro verwenden wenn man
den geschmack erregt also ist wohl ein
ganz exotischer geschmack an scheint ich
weiß es nicht aber interessant findest
du afrikanische kakaobohne fußball
schauen was in der verpackung gesehen
sie sehen aber nicht so schön gemacht
aus
sieht das in das sieht das innen drin
daneben wie anders aus im moment sieht
anders aus
ich probiere das jetzt mal und dann
gucke ich mir ob ich auf den geschmack
kommen
[Musik]
redknapp stimmt oder so irgendwie so
weitergeht sind spekulatius jetzt mal
gut wirklich probieren ja wie
weihnachtsgebäck hallo ich könnte jetzt
nicht so egger aber was ist das für ein
geschmack ist jetzt die frage und ich
habe keine ahnung
trotzdem zum video und geil trotzdem
halte rio solide solide leistung kann
man auf jeden fall zufrieden sein wie im
fußball
solide gespielt musik von der solide und
dadurch nicht solide gespielt er hat
verloren
wir haben ja und so angestrengt
geschmacks das solide machen so ein foto
von dir solide hatte dann war es
eigentlich schon allzu häufig viele
sachen an weiß 96 oder so in den anderen
essens box ist natürlich man ein
bisschen mehr drin aber trotzdem bedanke
ich mich ganz herzlich für dieses paket
hat mich sagen freut und mal schauen
wann wir als nächstes seine seite
gebrauchen können um wieder ein par-putt
news aus dem letzten monat zu testen
so kann es ja gerne weil nur selber so
experte auf dem gebiet ist und dann auch
manchmal solche sachen einkauft weil ich
habe nur sehr wenig von den ganzen
langen gefunden kannst du sehr gerne rum
schicken ansonsten gehe ich auch mal
selber einkaufen und sucht das aber das
wird es nochmal vereinfachen aber musste
auch nicht keine ahnung je nachdem wie
das seit ich dann noch hinhaut ansonsten
war es wird im video abonniert den kanal
blog aktivieren
wir sehen uns morgen 19 uhr wieder da
gibt's neues video und schon bei den
stürmern vorbei alex w es gibt sonst
irgendwas zu sagen ich glaube nicht oder
ist das video schon zehn minuten ist
hier die große frage finde ich machen
kannst du einen verstopften noch kurzen
tanz einlegen
und dann schalte man aber heute extra
viel wären weil man muss ja auch sagen
mein rucksack wollt ihr cloud macbook
weg irgendwo muss das geld ja wieder
reinkommen ist ja echt schade partie
hatten die partitur
[Musik]